Morning, Ben.
Hello, Ben, how are you?
Hello.
Good. Hey, guys.
Hey, Ben, do you know if Megan, Ashley, Jeremy?
if they will be able to join.
I don't know.
I hope they will.
Okay.
Let's wait, let's wait for a couple of minutes. Jerome is here, so that's good.
Is there me?
Hey, guys.
Good morning.
Hey, good morning. How you guys doing?
Pretty good, Jeremy. Thank you. It's Tuesday, so...
The.
Oh yeah.
There was still a few days for the weekend.
Six.
We're gonna get there.
Yeah, yeah, of course.
Jain.
Good morning, everyone.
Hey, Addy.
Maybe Jerome can tell us.
If Ashley Megan is available.
I can certainly check if you can give me a moment.
Of course.
Megan seems busy. Ashley is the way. That's what I can see it on my side.
Ohh.
She should, she might show busy because of this meeting. I don't know.
Okay.
Meantime, Ben, how's the weather?
Beautiful here today.
Yeah, if you check the background of Ben, it's beautiful and very good morning to you, Ben.
I'm feeling, I'm feeling cold if I look at the background, right? Mountains.
No.
Oops, what am I sharing?
Um...
Yeah, that's from my uh...
Do.
Holiday last summer, but it's pretty nice here in Atlanta today.
Mm.
We can go and get started if they're running late.
Yep.
Okay, perfect. So thank you and good morning everyone for joining. Addy, why don't you start first and I'll share the presentation. Okay.
Sure, thank you, Evan. Ben, so I have two to-dos for you. One is that connect twice access for the NOC team.
And other one is for list of the servers where we need to enable P1 alerts, offline alerts basically.
Oops, I keep doing that. Why do I keep doing that?
Oops.
This.
Um...
Maybe you weren't on the call, I'm okay.
No, what? What was the two things for me? What about...
Yeah.
Right.
One is for connectorize access.
Uh-huh.
We are unable to access manage. Other one is for the server list where we need to enable offline alerts.
Yeah, we're not using ConnectWise at all anymore, so we switched to Halo.
EE.
Okay.
Mm.
So I think we need to maybe change what we were doing over there.
Well, yeah, I mean, how are y'all connecting to ConnectWise? Because we haven't had access to ConnectWise in over a year. I mean, we have access, but...
No, we do either we don't have the access, but we are getting tickets on our hello, so we don't have any access to your PSA right now.
Ahh.
Mm.
OK, yeah, yeah, alright, I just.
The.
Yeah, I had brought that up on another meeting that we switched to Halo and wanted to get some assistance from you guys, but I don't think we ever followed up on that. But that's what we're using now. So if we can get connected to our Halo, that would probably be good.
EE.
For that, we need credentials then.
Uh, we'd have to get them a license bin, I assume.
I don't know, maybe it's just API, maybe it's like an API connection, and then they don't need a license.
Unless there's some type of API. Yeah.
I don't know; I can find out.
You find out what we need, Addy, like exactly, and then...
B.
Because Akshay and Rachel and Annie all have logins, but I don't.
If this is just for the CGM NOC, I don't CGM's.
Yeah.
They're crashing and burning.
So, um...
Kip.
They don't, I mean, they owe us a lot of money right now. I don't.
I don't want to pay for another license because if it's for their NOC stuff getting in there so they haven't they haven't paid us for the NOC services in like 6 months so.
Mmh.
Okay.
Yeah, I don't know what's going to happen with them, but they're falling apart.
OK.
But if we can get connected using the API, I think it would still be a good idea. Because I want to...
Yep.
possibly talk to you guys about some.
Azure monitoring that maybe would, we're moving a lot of our people to Azure and I'm setting up a lot of.
Azure type monitoring, but I think maybe it would be worth a conversation to see how we can, if you guys help us monitor that. Because right now, those emails come in, but we don't do anything with it. And I think it's, I think there's some opportunities there.
Of those.
Um...
I don't know, I figured you guys, I mean, with as more and more people are, you know, not having their own servers, maybe the NOC services would be shifting gears or something like that, but...
Yeah, let's figure that out.
Sure.
That was it from my side. Over to you, Khan.
Yep, thanks Addy. If you want, you can stay on the call or you can.
Disconnect as per your convenience.
Right.
Okay, so in the meantime, I'm going to share my screen and be able to go through the presentation. So ladies and gentlemen, please let me know when you can see my screen. Welcome, Ashley. Thank you so much for joining.
Hmm.
Sure, no problem. Sorry I was late.
It's okay. Do you know if Megan can join?
No, she's in the middle of a big project, so she will not be joining.
Yeah.
Okay.
We'll send the presentation copy to everyone. If she has any questions, then obviously she can get back to us. Okay, cool. So welcome to our monthly service review for NTI networks. We'll be looking at April month's performance. All right, the agenda item stays pretty much the same. We'll go through the highlights.
Great.
performance analysis, holiday schedule, AI by design, team GPS, way forward, and then meeting minutes.
Highlights, big one. Akshay is now SC300 and AZ104 certified. Vishal is now SC900 certified. I have already shared this big news with the team.
Very proud of the team that they're able to work on their growth and they're excelling in their career. So Ben, for you, I mean, I have sent you the link wherein you can look at their certificates. And if you would like to add...
to the profile on your side just to showcase your users, partners, that we have Microsoft certified engineers that will really provide value to your business.
Yeah, I love that. Also, for our Microsoft Partner, it's very nice to have those have them added in there.
Yep, and obviously, whenever they're working with the engineers, with the users, partners, they will appreciate that techs are certified, right? That's a big deal, actually, so that's why I said that's why I said that I'm proud of this team. They're continuously working on their level ups.
Yeah.
Me.
and happy that they are moving in the right direction.
Apart from this, Akshay, as usual, he is handling 90% of SOC alerts during early morning with incoming calls. And the team continues to meet service expectations with focus on SLA adherence and continuous improvement. Anything that you want to add, Ashley, Jeremy, Ben?
The.
before we move on to the next one.
I thought on my side.
Yeah.
Same.
No, I think we're good.
Okay. Now, since they both are certified, anything which you feel like they can focus on, let's say Q2 or Q3, any certification that you would like them to pursue. So do share it with me. I'll be more than happy to discuss with them.
Yeah.
I think that, I don't know, when Microsoft changed their partner account, their partner program, we lost our partner incentives from Microsoft. So we still get some of the incentives, but I'll let you know because we're trying to re-sign up.
IND.
for the Microsoft Azure kind of kickbacks that they give us. And there's, yeah, part of one of the things was we didn't have a right certification or something like that. So I'll let you know if there's something that would be helpful there.
First.
Yeah, of course. And as I mentioned, from our end, we just want to make sure team is doing certifications and learning as per the business needs. For example, if you feel like you will be getting a lot of Azure work, Office 365 work,
then certification towards these technologies will make more sense. So yeah, I mean, anything that you feel like that they're supposed to get their hands on, maybe look at 2026 down the line, just share it with me.
The.
B.
Okay.
Okay. And by the way, they both are working on their internal level ups as well on our side. So hopefully we'll share good news with you soon.
Sounds good.
All right, moving on with their performance analysis, looking at their billable utilization, Annie was at 53 percent, Rachel, Akshay, they both exceeded the benchmark score. Rachel, 65 percent, and Akshay being the rock star of this team, 86 percent.
That's their performance as for the month of April. Any questions, Ben, Jeremy, Anjali?
Ansh.
The.
No, I'm good.
No.
One thing, thank you. One thing that we discussed, Ben, as per Annie, if we can give her more work during the off hours, that would be great. Maybe if she can check on firewall, you know, upgrades, or anything which you feel like that she can utilize more of her work, that would be great.
Okay.
Yeah, and definitely.
I think we should do that.
All right, next up is the ticket closure rate, Annie was at 64%, Rachel 78%, Akshay 91%. We noticed that Annie's ticket closure rate is on the lower side because of after hours work, most of her tickets are rescheduled.
which impacts your ticket closure rate. But apart from this, the entire group is focused to meet their KPIs.
Sounds good.
Yeah, I was for a...
Ashley and Jeremy, like if there's things that, I mean, there's so many things I know that need to be checked on a regular basis that we're not doing. Let's think about that and get with Annie to, I mean, all this stuff that Mary Beth's all frustrated about, like, oh, which of these people not, you know, are acting.
Mm.
Yes.
There, or not here anymore, or...
You know, duo users on bypass. There's just, there's so many things. I mean, I just, I found another duo user that's been on bypass now for months and, you know, nobody caught that, so.
I think what we made.
Yeah.
So I think what would be best, and I'll try and start working on this, is to get a place in Hoodoo where we can have like, you know, duo check, duo bypass, and then how to check it, you know, because then that way we can just tell her what to do in the beginning.
So, Jeremy, I'll get with you. Maybe we can come up with a list.
Yeah, of course.
Yeah, and just to add to this, thank you, Ben, Ashley, Jeremy. If we can create a kind of a checklist wherein we can give it to Annie that, you know, these are the tasks after hours, that this is what you need to check going forward, and then she can share a report with all of us that this is what all she has done.
that will help us in a way that we'll be able to see the progress and see if we have to make any changes moving forward.
Sure.
Sounds good.
All right, moving on as per the holiday schedule. So the upcoming holiday is May 25th. That is Memorial Day. Now, do we need everyone on Memorial Day or can they take day off?
Nothing's gonna be happening here on Memorial Day. Do you guys agree?
I agree. Could I just we just need to figure out the on call is all.
Okay, it's Monday, so maybe Ashley, you can just let us know, then I can make the...
Kris.
Yes.
Yeah, we'll figure that out and I'll let you know.
Okay, cool. Yeah, so if you need any one of them, then I can connect with them.
I mean, I could be on call that day. I'm not doing anything, but there's everybody here will be off on Memorial Day, so...
Okay.
To.
Right, right. I just wanted to make sure we have it, since Annie is usually, we wouldn't have, we would just need to make sure is all. So that sounds good.
Yeah.
So what I'm hearing is for now, they can take the holiday. However, Ashley, you can just let us know maybe next week or, you know, close to 20.
Yes. Yeah, that's fine.
Yeah, I would imagine worst case scenario, if we can't have someone on our side handle it, it would probably just be maybe like a split shift. Probably just one person handles the normal warning and then Andy can just take over for the evening, like one and toward normal shift.
All right.
But we'll see as we get closer to that date.
Yeah.
Yeah, so from our side, and if anyone wants to work, then we'll give them a comp off. So we can do that as well. Because for us, it's not a, you know, Indian holiday. It's again a US holiday. So we want you guys to enjoy, right? And we can give them a comp of whosoever works on that day.
Sure.
Okay, that's the shift schedule. Well, the shift schedule remain the same, no change. But I have it on the slide just to see if this looks accurate or if there are any changes, then we can make the adjustments.
The.
Okay, next one is a big one. That's our Build It Live 2026 event. That's our annual event. I'm hoping that Ben you will be there.
Lee.
I am fairly certain, Ben, Mary Beth, and I are already registered from last year.
Awesome. Awesome.
Yeah, we're already signed up.
Awesome, true.
We will love to see all the pictures that you're gonna share, so that'll be great.
We are trying our best to see if Vishal can be there, so you never know.
Maybe, Ben, you need to push Vishal to be there.
Yeah, the more the merrier.
Okay.
He just needs too short on the call and he'll get anyone, you know, he'll just push you and tell you do it.
Yeah.
Ohh.
No, we would love to see all of you there. And I'm sure this is going to be fun and learning at the same point of time.
Yeah, it's a good one.
Perfect.
Yep. Thank you, Ben.
Um...
Great. AI by Design, our next event will be in the month of July. Right, Andy? I think I did share the dates with everyone.
This time it's clubbed with build it. It would be on 5th of August.
Yeah, well designed and there will be a visit to New York Stock Exchange and outing planned there in the evening.
Yeah.
Ohh.
Oh, perfect.
Ben is excited.
Yeah, I think right before, yeah, it's like a couple days before the...
That's interesting.
Build it, I think. Something like that.
Hmm.
I'm sorry, I could not understand the question correctly.
Yeah.
Oh, I said I just don't give a, is it after? Okay, I just knew it, it, it, it.
I think it's after.
It's after, right? Because...
Ketan.
Fifth, yeah, it's from 3rd to 5th, and it it's on 5th. AX later, along with the New York Stock Exchange routing, yeah, it's on 5th.
The.
Got it.
Dharam.
But.
But we'll share, we'll share the agenda with you, Ashley Ben. Yep, so we'll give you all the details. OK, alright, moving on with...
Yeah, it will be emails will be coming, yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, that'd be perfect.
Team GPS, this is something that's our in-home platform. So if you need any more information about it, you have the QR code on the screen, you can scan it and we'll...
And.
Schedule a demo.
Way forward, well, it remained the same. We just want to make sure the entire group is motivated and...
in line with the business needs. So that's our focus for the remaining Q2 and 2026. Wherever you feel like team can take on more work, would be like any particular technology. So just feel free to share it with us. We'll be more than happy to.
They call the arrangements and making sure that they are providing value to NTN.
Sounds good.
Yeah.
Um...
I don't think I had anything. I think the last time I spoke with Mary Beth, and I don't know, because I was out of town, so I don't know if this was discussed or not. But for the notes, we, I know Mary Beth had spoken with the three of them.
Dubey.
about putting all their like detailed notes into the internal side, basically like logged on to server, X, Y, Z, you know, all that stuff, which not everything we need, like we don't need to know like that they logged on to the server, we just need to know what server, you know. But for the,
Yep.
Yeah, I was going to say the same thing. Like actually puts really good notes in, but it'll say like, did this complicated thing, but he doesn't say what he did. Like the note just says, you know,
It's like, I don't know, the notes must be coming, the notes are obviously being generated by some kind of a tool. I don't know, AI or some kind of a generation tool. That's obvious. But it doesn't have, like sometimes if I want to say, how did you fix that?
I go to the old ticket where the exact same problem happened, and then...
It says it was fixed, but it doesn't say how to fix it. And then I have to bother Akshay because the way to fix it wasn't in the ticket. So that would be a little bit better if we either had the actual detail of how something was fixed in the ticket.
Mm.
or if it's something that he had to research and figure out.
I've asked everyone to like, yeah, what I was just going to say, I've, but the other thing I've said is, look, if you either put it in the ticket or make an article in our Hoodoo, our documentation system, and then the ticket put a link to that. Because I wish I could have the exact example, but he did something the other day that was a,
No, that that is that is that is a very fair ask, yeah.
Mhm.
I couldn't figure it out and I didn't want to spend time. And I said, Akshay, could you figure this out for me? And obviously he fixed it perfectly. But then the same thing happened and I had to call him again because the ticket just said it was fixed. It didn't say how it was fixed.
Yeah, and I think, well, just to follow up on that, like that, that, yes, we want the info, the detailed info, but it needs to be in the internal side, or like Ben said, article, so that when we're sending invoices to the clients, that they're only seeing the public side of the notes.
Yeah.
Team.
which would be basically like, you know, the actual communication with the clients and I resolve the issue, things like that. So just to keep it short, because when it's really long and detailed, then it shows up on the invoice weird. So, but that was, that's all I had. And then I've got to, I've got to jump.
Mhm.
But I'll check in with Jeremy and Ben if there's anything else.
Mmh.
Yeah.
Okay, thanks. So that is a fair ask and logs should be definitely descriptive, easy to understand from a layman language as well, layman person as well that what was done, it should be there in logs. And I believe this is a quick fix, easy to fix, Chauhan and myself, we can talk to them and we can make them understand.
Of Kour.
Well, thanks.
Yeah.
What is the what is the ask from your side, so you will definitely see some improvement in the logs on the in the notes bin.
Yeah, and I do feel like in that regard that there may be some exceptions to the rule. Like if we have them involved in certain projects, things are going to take a little bit more time. And Ben, you can kind of chime in on this as well. Like sometimes we do have to justify how much time we're spending on some things.
Mhm.
So it's like keep it detailed, but keep it within reason. But for the most part, what we're kind of asking for is that like any like public notes for just regular old tickets, try to sum it up at like, you know, one to two lines for the most part. And then just like any sort of detailed information, just make sure that's in the internal notes. Internal is not billable, but progress notes are billable. So.
Yep.
Yeah, get that. We're on the same page, Jomi.
Mhm.
Noted. So thank you. Ashley is not here, but we appreciate the insight and we'll make the adjustments accordingly. As Vishal and we all agree that it's a minor fix. I think we just need to tell the team to make a little tweak to this and I'm sure going forward you'll see.
Kour.
Yeah, just add this to the agenda, the weekly call we have with the team covered, and we can we can discuss it over there. So this is doable, and we will take care of that, Ben and Jeremy.
Sure.
Yep.
Cool. Thank you, Jerome, over to you. Anything else apart from this?
Um...
No, not really. I mean, I guess I just want to, I was thinking about kind of having a one on one with the team and everything to kind of just, you know, see how things are kind of working and see how they're progressing and things like that. Because there are like a few hiccups here and there, very like super minor stuff though. Especially just, you know, making sure that title descriptions are being updated to
Dhiman.
something that's not just like PT is broken. You know, just something we can kind of quickly identify, things like that. Also, there's like a little minor issue, I suppose, with like Annie specifically. I just want to make sure that she's kind of understanding when escalations need to be kicked over to me. You know, I only work until 530.
Mhm.
But I still try to be there as a resource whenever she needs it. She knows to message me and, you know, I'll be the one to answer whatever questions she may have. But some of the stuff is just kind of stuff that I feel like she should know at her level. It's nothing complicated that requires any sort of expertise.
Um...
But that's about it. That's probably something I could probably just address with her just in 101.
Yeah, and thank you, thank you, Jeremy, for sharing. One thing that I've also requested her, because I connected, I do connect with them, you know, every now and then. And I spoke to any day before yesterday, that was on Friday. I told her that whenever you're reaching out to anyone,
Like anyone in the team, you need to keep things very descriptive, like what is the issue, what have you done, and what is the ask? So that the other person understands that this is what the ask is. Otherwise, you know, engineers, they have this, you know, tendency.
Exactly.
to paste the notes. They'll give you everything, but they'll not tell you what exactly you need. So this is where I'm just trying to coach them, wherein they are being very specific that this is what they are looking for as per the help. So hopefully you'll see improvement on this front as well. And going forward, if you see they are reaching out to you directly without this piece, then you should ask.
What is the issue? What have you done? And what is the ask? So I think it will help all of us, and it will also make sure that, you know, that efficiency and that productivity will definitely increase.
Right.
Okay, thank you, Jeremy. Ben, over to you.
Um, no, I'm good. I think just what Jeremy said, like, it's...
I think that sometimes, I mean, maybe there's language issues or something, but sometimes I'm like, oh, they fixed some super complicated thing last week, but now this week they don't understand a basic question. So I don't know if that's more language issue or what, but you know,
I um...
I don't feel like there's a major problem, but I have every once in a while I'm like, what? Like, why didn't they, you know, how did they not know that? So, but I just would encourage them to keep reaching out. I mean, Rachel's been doing a pretty good job of pinging me.
Yeah.
Mm-hmm.
when she needs help or if she has any questions. Same with Akshay. I haven't received, I don't know, I haven't received really hardly anything from Annie.
Maybe she doesn't want to bother you during all parts.
Maybe she, yeah, yeah, scared of you.
Um...
No, I need to, I want them to bother me. No, she, okay, she did reach out to me last week. Um, let's see.
Yeah.
Yeah, I just, I mean, all I would say is make sure they know it's fine to reach out for me if they have questions, even if it's after hours. I mean, I'm up, you know, she's working till 9:00 our time. It's, you know, I'm up until 11 or midnight every day. So I'm happy to help.
Thank you for being that open, Ben, and in offering your help. Really, really appreciate that.
That that.
Yeah, okay. Oh, here it is. Here it is. So a user, we switched a user to, we switched a company from Google Business to Microsoft. And
Yep.
So their emails were on Google and we moved them over to Microsoft. And so they have several remote users. I'm going to share my screen here. This is just, I think, Jeremy, this might be sort of an example of what you're talking about here. This, okay. All right, so here it is.
Mhm.
Right.
All right, now.
The user's email is supposed to be...
For some reason, she told him it was this.
Row at Pinnacle X-ray dot on Microsoft.com. OK, so.
Like, no, that's never, no one's ever going to use that email. And anyone who knows anything about Microsoft knows that the on Microsoft.com is kind of the temporary initial setup. So when we have someone who's supposed to be, like I said,
Mhm.
Yeah.
No.
I think Annie does great. However, I'm very surprised that she would tell someone that this is their email address. This would never be someone's email address.
ever. I mean, no one would use that for an email address. Now, that's their initial user login where we're doing the cutover, but...
Exactly.
Yep, yep, very true, very true.
The email is rdixon at pxsinc.com. And I think Jeremy's saying we kind of have an expectation that they would at least know those basics.
Yep, absolutely.
So that's the kind of thing. Now, that's not a major, like she's still pretty good at the other thing. She was able to get them logged in. I mean, she'd taken it past that. But recognizing this is important, I think.
It's.
The...
No, this is this is a good example. Sorry, Jerome, go ahead.
Yeah, I mean, like the...
Like.
I don't know. Well, I was gonna say, I mean, like our biggest concern is really just, so the shift that she has could potentially be harder than the rest of the shifts that the other technicians have, because essentially you're working a shift after 530 where you have no one to really rely on. You are on your own, but you know, you can still.
She can still obviously like call me and things like that, but I may or may not be available or Ben, you know, that sort of thing. So I do kind of feel like, you know, if you're going to be working that kind of shift, you should have almost probably like a higher level of experience than actually a Rachel. That's my concern. She's getting better at some things, but there are also some other times in which, you know, we do get calls on certain things where it's just like,
It takes us two seconds to spot out an obvious problem, like the on Microsoft account. Um, I'm not trying to thrash on Annie. I, you know, I know she's doing her best. I know she does reach out to me when she needs assistance, but you know...
You do gotta draw a line somewhere, you know.
Yeah.
No, totally hear you, totally hear you on that point. Um, if you could just...
I agree.
I'll just, I'll just check.
Yeah, just go ahead, Gagan. I think we are talking the same language. Go ahead.
Yeah, yeah.
Yes, so thank you. Thank you, Vishal. So sorry to interrupt you. Let me follow with Annie on this. I just need to understand her thought process, that what exactly she was thinking, because as Ben also mentioned, sometimes engineers are thinking from a different perspective, right? And we just need to make sure that they understand what the ask is.
Even though it's very clear, it's very clear that the email address should be the one which has the actual email address, right? So I just wanted to understand and I'm sure as Jeremy also mentioned.
Right, but...
Yeah, but again, I don't want this to look like, I don't want her to be afraid to call me now if he's like, hey, she put this in wrong and Ben brought it up. Tell her I'm thinking, I'm told she did great.
Right, he will call you.
Ben, your Ben, your your message is very clear, Ben, and we always appreciate this transparency and you know that you're open for support and feedback. I would say this is a good example to talk to her that you know to just figure it out exactly what's going on in case if there was any distraction or.
Yeah.
Doing multitasking, sometimes that could lead to these kind of things, but again, this is a good example to talk to her and, you know, tell her this, you know, as Yomi said, this set of expectations that has to be there. We will take care of that, sir. No, no, absolutely, yes.
Yeah, but I don't want her to be afraid to call me because of this. I want her to be more willing to call me. If she has any question, just have her reach out.
Yeah.
I'm pretty sure the environment that you have created and this team has created for NTI people, for our people who are working for you, they are not afraid of anything. Let me tell you that. They are always gaga. Whenever we talk about Jeremy, we talk about you, Ben, they're always happy to talk about, they're happy for the support they're getting from you.
Mm.
Okay, good.
So don't worry about that. We will definitely share your feedback, but in a way that she gets her listen, but not afraid of us or afraid of you for any XYZ reason.
Okay.
Yeah, we'll take care of that. Thank you so much, Ben. One more thing from my side, Ben, I'm sure that is why I still see Andy on this call, although this is like, you know, 4 minutes past with this call. I wanted to quickly align on the renewal for Akshay. I know we just time is...
Thank you.
Alright.
Yes.
We're already 4 minutes away. Do you have any availability? Ben we can connect again to just talk about the renewal and for Akshay, that is today or tomorrow we can connect.
Um, today...
Let's see, on to the airport tomorrow at noon. I mean, let's, I could talk.
Oh shoot. Yeah, today maybe like 3, 3 o'clock, 4 o'clock.
I'm available at 3:00. Andy, sir, what about you?
Okay. Send me an invite so I don't forget.
Yep.
Yeah, I'll send it, but...
No worries. Please, please accept one. Yeah, I mean, expect one invite either from me or Andy, and then we can connect. Thank you so much for your time, Ben. Thank you, Jeremy.
Okay.
All right. Okay. Bye.
Thank you, Tina. Have a good day. Bye.
Thank you, guys.
Bye. Thank you.
Thank you, Team. Take care. Bye bye.
That boy.